professor chomsky
the following question comes from joseph
felikovsky of newcastle so there have
been some developments in evolutionary
biology
in the field of mimetics which are
different units of culture behaviors
that we pass down from one generation to
the next and
they evolve and they follow evolutionary
algorithms
that was popularized by dockings now
when we look at mimetics there is the
philosopher daniel dennett who posits
that
for understanding language or in the
quest to understand language you can use
mimetics to understand certain
linguistic
algorithms that is to say that language
evolves
in the same way that biological cultures
evolve gene cultures evolve
i was curious if you've heard of the
field of mimetics
and if you had any opinions on that
field
well for the this proposal that you
mentioned
has a number of problems one problem
is it doesn't give an explanation for
anything
try to give an example take the example
that was just given
uh does it say anything about wanna
contraction
no does it say anything about anything
else about language
no that's one problem the other problem
is that we have some
evidence about evolution of language and
it doesn't seem to work anything like
that
we don't have a lot of evidence but we
have some could run through it
just uh give a counter point or an
example to
to defend mathematics for a bit take
for example the phenomena we notice
when we have expats living in a
colony in the development of their
language versus the development of
language in a main
so i'll give a very concrete example
take the english
and then the american colonists
the american colonists spoke heroic
english i believe
and over time the mainland population
of english the english that we know
the people in england speak and britain
speak it evolved into the queen's
english
while the colony population has sort of
maintained heroic english
we notice a similar type of phenomena
with the french and the
quebecers the chinese and the straight
chinese of
singapore well a very similar thing
happens
in biology in population dynamics in
fact
if you have a population of mainland
population
and you take out different individuals
from that mainland population and you
put them on an island
the mainland population will evolve at a
faster rate
than the uh island population
and they'll sort of be not stuck out of
time they don't
totally stop evolving neither in biology
or linguistics
but it's an example of an evolutionary
algorithm
that seems to hold with linguistics
except that it has nothing to do with
evolution we have to distinguish
evolution from change
languages change all the time but
there's no linguistic evolution
evolution means something that's
happening
basically to your to your to your
genetics to your dna
that's evolution and there's pretty good
evidence that
there has been no evolution of the
language faculty
for a couple hundred thousand years so
humans began
to this is a common misunderstanding
but change is not evolution
the american colonists and the british
who stayed on the mainland had the same
language faculty it hadn't changed if
you had taken
an american colonists child
and raised them in london they'd speak
exactly like the people in london
and conversely in fact if you take
an american kid today as an infant
and you raise him in a tribe in the
amazon
he'll speak their language perfectly the
reason is as far as we know
there has been no evolution of the
language faculty
ever since language emerged and for that
there's
fairly good evidence the
we know from genomic evidence that
humans began to separate
roughly 150 000 years ago
at least that much maybe earlier but
that's the earliest has been traced
well you take the people who separated
basically the sun people in africa
uh that same language faculty we do as
far as anyone knows
there's just no evidence for and in fact
what i said about raising a an american
infant in
the amazon as far as we know that's true
quite generally
so there's there's literally no evidence
that the language faculty has
evolved at all since language first
emerged
which is not very surprising these are
very short periods of evolutionary time
the 200 000 years in evolution is an
instant
i think we are confusing the tree with
its fruits that is to say
the mechanisms of evolution genetics
haven't necessarily well they have
changed as well just as
the language faculty over time has
changed at one point right we were
at one point over a grand scale i mean
at one point we were
and descendants from amphibians right
and we evolved at some point to have
language so the language faculty if it
is intrinsic to us would have had to
evolve at some point
but uh my point is is that for in both
cases the island population in the
mainland population
the mechanism of evolution i.e genetics
is the same
the linguistic evolution uh i.e
the linguistic faculty for the americans
and the
bostonians and the english was the same
but if you would the software
has changed has evolved in both cases
that's just like saying that my language
is different from your language which it
is
i speak differently than you do but we
are much smarter
we have the same language faculty it's a
serious mistake to confuse
evolution with change now it might be
that some of the phenomena
in change have a sort of an analogy
to things that happen in evolution but
that's just an analogy
it's a totally different process uh the
evolutionary change involves genetic
change
a change in the way people behave
that for all kind of reasons that it
changes so in fact
we can talk about language evolution and
there is work on that
but these other things are just the
study of language change which may have
some loose analogy to things that
happened within evolution